- Good afternoon, everyone,
and welcome to day one of re:Invent.
We're very pleased to have you all join us
to discuss training
high-performance AI models
on AWS using SageMaker.
I am Michael Oguike, I'm a
senior product manager on Amazon,
and I work on AWS SageMaker
where we help customers train
high-performance models.
With me today is Tomonori Shimomura,
who is a principal solutions architect
who also works on SageMaker
and helps customers train AI models.
We're very pleased to be
joined by Denis Goupil,
who's also a principal
machine learning scientist
from Roblox,
and they're gonna be sharing
an exciting use case with us.
Today, we're gonna go through the need
to train large AI models.
We're gonna discuss the challenges
that we see in training
these large models,
and then we'll discuss how SageMaker helps
to resolve these challenges.
Then Tomonori would come back up,
and show us an actual
demo followed by Roblox
with Denis coming back up to
show us a real life example
of how they've built a 4D
foundational model using SageMaker
and HyperPod.
Before we go on, by a quick show of hands,
how many of us in the
audience have trained
or customized a large model?
Okay. And how many of you have
done that using SageMaker?
Great.
So there's gonna be a lot of capabilities
that we'll share and a
lot to also learn here.
But before we even go deeper,
I think a couple of you may have noticed
the growing popularity
of this sparkle icon.
You may have seen it on your re:Invent app
where it's helping you to try
to get more out of your week,
or you may have noticed
it on your playlist
where AI is trying to help
you create a better playlist,
or even on autonomous
driverless cars on the road.
For me, even while
building this presentation,
as I was trying to crop photos,
AI was there trying to help
me crop my photos better,
but behind each of these
icons is a trained model,
and as your customers and your
users are getting more used
to using AI to improve their experience,
you are also gonna be needing
to add more capable models
to the experiences that
you already deliver
for your customers.
And in fact, we see this in studies.
A study by McKinsey showed
that 47% of companies
who said they were using
generative AI were also training
or customizing these AI models
to better serve their use cases.
Now, we built SageMaker for AI
as we've seen the trend moving
on forward for you to help
to build more capable
models for your customers,
it's important that we have
the right capabilities for you,
our customers, to build and
train and deploy these models.
We started this journey in 2017
when we launched SageMaker training jobs.
SageMaker training jobs
offers you a fully managed API
where all you need to do is
bring in your training data,
you bring in your training script,
you tell us which instances you wanna run,
and we take all that input,
we spin up a cluster, we train the model,
and we deliver the model
artifact to an S3 bucket.
It's an ephemeral cluster and
you only pay for what you use.
And our customers had a
great experience with that,
and they continue to use training jobs.
But then we had customers like you ask
for more capabilities such as being able
to manage the cluster
using Slurm or Kubernetes.
We had customers asking
for more granular control
and observability to these clusters.
And there were also customers
who wanted more persistent clusters
so they could both run training jobs
and inference jobs on
the same infrastructure.
So we launched SageMaker
HyperPod to meet these needs.
So in the conversation today,
and the two key capabilities
that we have are one,
SageMaker training jobs, which
is the ephemeral compute,
or SageMaker HyperPod,
which is more persistent.
These are the two key
services that SageMaker offers
for you to train your models.
As we've continued to work with you
and other customers to learn
about what matters most to you
for training large AI models,
we've seen six key dimensions.
One, compute availability,
two, performance,
then there's resiliency,
there's observability.
Number five, ease of use,
and most importantly, cost.
Every level that we move on each
of these five dimensions has
a direct impact on your cost.
And in the next couple of slides,
I'm gonna dive deeper
into the first three,
computer availability,
performance, and resiliency.
And when Tomonori comes up,
he's gonna go deeper into observability,
and ease of use when we walk
through the demo together.
With compute availability,
let's first of all look at the trend
that we've been observing
over the last couple of years.
We've seen that over the
last couple of years,
we've been needing to use more compute
to train more capable models.
This is primarily driven by the fact
that we need more training data,
and we're also training these
models with more parameters
so they can be more capable,
they're more accurate,
like using them in cases
like in the legal field
or in the medical sciences
or in autonomous driving.
We need bigger models
so they're more capable.
Now, over the last two to three years,
we've actually gotten to the point
where we're now using 10 to the power
of 24 FLOPs of compute power
to train these very
highly performance models.
And the scientific notation
for 10 to the power of 24 is,
wait for it.
It's a (indistinct) FLOP, but
let's make that more concrete.
What's a (indistinct) FLOP?
Five (indistinct) FLOPs is the equivalent
of running 1000 p5s GPUs
consistently for one month.
That's a lot of compute
power, that's very expensive,
and that's why it's essential
that we optimize the
utilization of these GPUs,
but we also want access to
the most performance compute
so we can get our training
jobs done quickly.
To do this, SageMaker offers
multiple capabilities for you
to get the best compute
whenever you want it.
So we have a wide selection of your GPUs
and accelerators from the H100 single GPUs
to GP 200 ultra servers.
You can get single GPU jobs
or even a 72 GPU ultra server within Iraq
depending on your needs.
But that's one thing, selecting the GPU.
We also understand that
your business needs
and your timelines are different.
So we have various options
to secure capacity,
whether that's using on-demand capacity
or you can get spot capacity
for up to 90% cheaper
than on-demand capacity.
And in fact, just last
week on SageMaker HyperPod,
we launched support for spot instances,
which is great for
fault tolerant workloads
and experimentation.
Or if you want a longer term reservation
where you have guaranteed capacity,
you can get a one year reservation
or three-year reservation
with reserved capacity.
And if you're looking
for something in between,
where there's a calendar
period, say, next month,
you want to get capacity for
a particular period of time,
you can use the flexible training plans.
Well, now that we've got GPUs,
what are we gonna do with them?
As important as it is to
get the compute capacity,
it is even more important that
we utilize them effectively
to avoid wastage.
With SageMaker,
you have the option to use
the training jobs managed API,
where you just submit the job
and we handle the scheduling
and the distribution of
the jobs across the GPUs.
Or you can also use Slurm and Kubernetes
depending on what your scientists
are more familiar with.
Or if you have a team where
you have multiple team members
and you have different type of jobs
and you wanna prioritize
the different jobs,
you wanna allocate capacity
to different teams
within your organization,
you can use a capability
we call task governance
on HyperPod where you
can allocate resources
to different teams or you
can give a higher preference
to say, an inference
job over a training job.
And whenever an inference job comes,
it preempts the training job.
We also have an integration with AWS batch
that also allows you to do this
with SageMaker training jobs.
All these capabilities
come together to ensure
that you have the right compute capability
and you're able to optimize
utilization of these GPUs
or accelerators, so you
reduce your cost for training.
We then talk about performance.
And to discuss performance,
let's quickly demonstrate the relationship
between the amount of memory
required by the parameters
in a model compared to the
available memory per GPU
for a lot of the latest
GPUs and accelerators.
On this chart, we have two trends.
There's one trend that's
showing the higher incline,
which shows the number
of parameters in a lot
of the popular models
over the last 10 years.
And we can see, like we
talked about earlier,
this growth in the number
of parameters required
for these large models.
On the other hand, on the gentler slope,
we can see the slope on how
the memory per GPU is changing
over time, and we can see that the number
of parameters is growing
faster than the memory per GPU.
Now, the implication of this really,
we can demonstrate this with one example,
say the Llama 3-70B model,
the amount of GPU memory that we need
to train a 70 billion parameter model,
we can calculate that
by getting the amount
of memory each parameter requires.
And on average the rule of
thumb is like 18 to 20 bytes
when you account for the weights
and you account for the gradients
and the optimizer states,
so we say 20 bytes times
70 billion parameters,
that requires almost 1.4 terabytes
of data of memory on the GPU.
Now, even the NVIDIA H100
is 80 gigabytes of memory.
So you do not have enough memory per GPU
to load and train the model.
So to overcome this scaling challenge,
we then have to do what we
call distributed training.
And some of you are
probably familiar with this,
so I'll go over this quickly,
but basically, for example,
in the Llama 70B model case
where we have more parameters
and more memory from the model
than we can put on one
GPU, what we then do is
to shard the model
across the different GPUs
and distribute the training
across the different GPUs.
And as training happens
in step synchronously,
the different GPUs can then
communicate across each other
to update their state,
but then the data is small enough for us
to replicate the data
across the different GPUs.
So each GPU is actually doing
a micro batch of the training
and then updating states as they go along.
And that's model parallelism
where we split the model,
but we replicate the data.
Conversely, if we have a
large training data set,
but we have a small enough model,
say, a Llama 3.21 billion parameter model
that we can fit onto one H100,
because again, it's 20 gigabytes of model
versus 80 gigabytes of GPU memory.
In that case,
we can split the training data
across the different GPUs,
replicate the model
do the training in batches,
and have all the GPUs synchronized states
as they train oversteps and epochs.
One thing we might observe
here is at this point,
the networking becomes very important
because the GPUs have to update states
and communicate with
one another over time.
If we even step more complex
where we're both distributing
the training data
as well as sharding the model.
We've sharded the model
across various layers
in the neural network.
We've also sharded the model
across different tensiles.
So in this case, we're doing a hybrid
of both data parallelism
and model parallelism.
But what's most important here
is that your networking can
quickly become a bottleneck.
You need high bandwidth,
low latency communication
between all the nodes to ensure
that you're not spending
more time than you need
on the training job.
SageMaker offers multiple
capabilities to ensure
that you're getting the
most performant high speed
networking when you are
running these training jobs.
First, we have an automated easy setup
where you can use the
CLI, SDK, CloudFormation,
or even the Console to set up
your distributed training job.
We have access to multiple
popular frameworks
like PyTorch, TensorFlow, or even Ray.
And on the communication libraries,
you can use NVIDIA NCCL,
or if you're using Trainium instances,
you can use the Neuron Collective
Communication libraries.
And for high-speed networking,
you have access to the NVLink
technology from NVIDIA,
or for internet connectivity,
you have access to Elastic
Fabric Adapter from Amazon
where you can get up to
3,200 GPS of bandwidth.
All these together help to ensure
that you have an efficient
distributed training set up,
where your GPUs and your
training jobs are connecting
and moving at a very high
speed, which is essential
for reducing your time to
market and being cost-efficient.
Finally, we talk about resiliency.
To discuss resiliency,
we quickly bring back
our favorite single GPU.
Each of these GPUs has
a mean time to failure.
And when we scale these
GPUs to a large number,
say, hundreds or thousands of GPUs,
we then move from a GPU-level resiliency
to a job-level resiliency
because every failure from
every GPU in the cluster
can potentially interrupt the
progress of your entire job.
And we've actually seen this in research.
So research from Meta that was published
in IEEE early this year showed
where they run an experiment
on two large state
of the art clusters for about 11 months.
And if you follow the lower line,
they saw that for jobs
running with 1024 nodes,
the average time to failure
was about eight hours.
So that's three failures in
one day, one for breakfast,
one for lunch, and one to
wake you up at two o'clock
in the morning with a page.
But how does SageMaker help
us resolve these issues
and prevent us from getting paged?
We have a four pronged strategy,
mitigation, prevention,
detection, and recovery.
And the way we achieve this
is basically with mitigation,
we encourage and we make it easy for you
to checkpoint your training.
So you're taking multiple safe steps.
So even if something goes wrong two days,
one week into the future,
you're not losing all
your training progress
and we're able to restart
from a checkpoint.
Sometime this year,
we also launched
managed-tiered checkpointing,
which basically reduces
the penalty of having
to checkpoint frequently
because there could be network penalties
or even storage penalties.
But with managed-tiered checkpointing,
you have a more efficient,
faster checkpoint process,
and you see that when
Tomonori also shows his demo.
For prevention, we have
multiple types of health checks
with standard health checks
or deep health checks
where essentially before
we add a node to your job,
we do a burning test
and we really pressure
test these instances.
So if there's actually a problem
with any of these instances
or GPUs, we can isolate that
instance from the cluster
so it never even makes
it into your cluster.
For detection, we have automatic
health monitoring agents
that are continually
running through the cluster
and running through your job
to identify any issues and resolve them.
And then finally, for recovery,
in the event that something does happen,
we identify like there's
a slow GPU or a slow node,
we can automatically reboot the node.
Or if that doesn't resolve the issue,
we will automatically replace the node
and then restart the job
from your checkpoint.
So once again, all these
capabilities come together
and we've seen cases
where it saves up to 40%
of the time spent on training,
which essentially helps you
save on your overall cost
because you're able to
respond to failures faster.
So I would now invite
Tomonori on to show us a demo
of these in action.
- Thank you. Yeah, thank you, Michael.
Am I audible? Yeah, thank you.
So I'm Tomonori Shimomura,
a solutions architect on
SageMaker AI organization
that's helping SageMaker
AI customers every day.
And now, Michael covered
the fundamental concept
of SageMaker AI training capability.
So let's dive deep into the
actual developer experience
including demonstration.
So as Michael explained,
there are two training capabilities,
SageMaker training jobs and HyperPod.
And SageMaker training job
provides free managed APIs.
So before executing the job,
SageMaker training job
automatically creates a cluster
and after the execution of the job,
it automatically (indistinct) the cluster.
So essentially the computer
resource is allocated only
during the job execution, so
you can inspect a lower cost.
And you can use high
(indistinct) Python SDK,
and it's a kind of wrapper
Python library on top
of SageMaker service API.
And you can easily use
SageMaker training capability
by writing Python code
or running notebooks.
And because this is based on
the SageMaker service API,
you can easily integrate the training job
with your MLops pipeline.
This is an example called
fragment of training job.
And as you can see,
this Python code is
importing a Python module
called SageMaker core,
and instantiating, sorry,
creating a training job object,
bypassing some parameters
like a hyper parameter
configuration instance
type, instance count,
and container image, right?
By providing these say,
parameters, you can define,
oh say, configure the training
job, start the training job
and automatically create
cluster internally.
And another training capability
from SageMaker is HyperPod.
And unlike SageMaker training job,
HyperPod is for persistent clusters.
So it means cluster
creation is not automatic,
unlike SageMaker training job.
And that you need to say,
explicitly create and delete clusters,
but the HyperPod helps you create
such a high performance cluster easily.
So you can customize the
cluster based on your needs
and share the cluster with
your teammate, multiple users,
and execute multiple
jobs on the same cluster.
That's the difference from
the SageMaker training job.
And as Michael said,
SageMaker comes with advanced
resiliency capability.
I'd like to explain a
little bit more later,
and I also included some
demonstration in my say, a video.
Yeah.
And because SageMaker HyperPod
is for AI development purpose, right?
Not a normal cluster.
So it's an AI development
purpose to cluster.
So it comes with AI purpose,
comprehensive observability dashboard,
and also some useful libraries
and tools to optimize your training.
HyperPod supports two
orchestrator options.
One is from, and another
is EKS or Kubernetes.
EKS is Amazon's Elastic Kubernetes Service
and it's actually Kubernetes, right?
And both support,
I think Slurm and the EKS
are both powerful framework
to run distributed training,
but developed by experience are different.
So I'd like to explain how
they are different briefly.
So Slurm is our open source
job orchestration framework,
and you can basically run a same batch job
on multiple nodes.
Simple word, right?
And in case of HyperPod,
you will create three types of node,
control (indistinct) node,
computer nodes, and a login node.
Typically you log into log nodes
and execute Slurm commands such as srun,
srun (indistinct) for
sbatch, and SQ, et cetera,
to learn from features.
And another orchestrator
is EKS or Kubernetes.
I think many people have had Kubernetes
because it's popular, right?
And Kubernetes is, let's
say framework to run,
or containerized the applications,
various types of
containerized applications
including distributed
training applications.
And unlike Slurm orchestration,
in case of choosing Kubernetes,
the HyperPod cluster only
contains computer nodes
because controlled brain, say,
EKS plays that load of control brain,
HyperPod cluster itself doesn't
contain controlled brain
or login nodes.
And you can learn,
say, Kubernetes clients
like a cube controller
or your preferred Kubernetes client
on your development machine,
even on your local laptop, right?
Yeah.
So which is better choice for you?
This is a tough question
because this is case by case.
So if you already have a
preferred choice of orchestration,
please choose it.
And if you want to
directly access hardware,
if you want to run application
on hostable directory,
so that may be, right, the choice,
if you love containerized,
maybe Kubernetes or EKS
maybe the better choice.
Yeah, I think Michael
already covered some portion
of resiliency, but let me recap quickly
before going to the actual demonstration.
So HyperPod resiliency,
so resiliency consists
of three steps, right?
Health monitoring, instance replacement,
the job auto-resuming.
So these three are the,
let's say, core, let's say,
flow of HyperPod resiliency.
So HyperPod constantly health checks.
And if we find some GPU 40 instance,
we triggered instance replacement,
and after the instance replacement,
they suspended the job
automatically (indistinct).
We provide such a framework.
Yeah, so we directed to two demos.
I captured pre-recorded videos,
and partially I accelerated video
because in order to fit
this limited time session.
So starting from SageMaker training jobs,
and I'm going to open
a code data on browser.
SageMaker has a code, say,
code data browser by the way.
And I execute a notebook
in order to trigger
that training job.
And eventually we will
see the execution result
on training metrics by MLflow.
Yeah, so firstly I'm opening
Code Editor on SageMaker
of clicking open bottom,
and it looks like say, visual studio.
I said this is based on
the open source version
of visual studio, code editor.
And checking, browsing the training code.
This is the code actually
executed on computer resource.
And I'm executing notebook.
And the first half of this notebook
is for data pre-processing
and uploading to S3 bucket.
This is a preparation step.
Yeah, visualizing the training data set
and configuring some
parameters for training job,
uploading S3.
Okay.
And then creating or
configuring the training job.
(audience chattering)
Yeah.
Yeah, so you can see
a model trainer class,
I mean instant setting model trainer class
with some parameters.
This is the Python API.
And then actually say,
configuring input channels,
the input data channels
and starting the training.
And you can also see the list
of SageMaker training job on
SageMaker management console
like this.
So now it's showing training status,
training is in progress, and
the progress can be also seen
by visiting crowd of watch
logs management console.
You can see output from
(indistinct), right?
Yeah, so there are some options,
how to monitor the progress.
You can see CloudWatch logs,
you can use also a notebook
by interacting, by calling
some method of Python object,
you can get the log output as well.
And also after this, I will show,
but you can also check MLflow out of,
or your preferred
observability solution as well.
So SageMaker has MLflow,
manage the MLflow.
So I click the MLflow button
and opening the MLflow,
and I'm seeing a list of
executed training jobs
and you can see training
metrics like this.
Yep, so next demo is SageMaker HyperPod.
And in this demo, I'm going
to create a cluster easily
and configuring, so
customizing the cluster
by installing some add-ons
and learning some training job
and I'm going to, so in this demo,
I did say simulating some
hardware failure artificially
by injecting (indistinct) simulated error
and verify that HyperPod resiliency works,
and eventually see the
observability dashboard.
Yeah, so you can easily create
a SageMaker HyperPod cluster.
And in case of quick setup,
what you have to do is just
choose right instance type
and instance count,
basically that's it, right?
So cluster creation can be
complex if you do manually,
but we provide such an
easy setup experience.
And actual cluster creation
progress can be monitored
on cloud formation management console
because it requires not
only cluster itself,
but also require various politic resources
such as VPC or subnet
security group, S3 bucket,
and (indistinct), et cetera, right?
And when HyperPod cluster
is getting created,
we can visit SageMaker management console
and see the instance
initialization progress
at the instance level.
Now, so yeah, I think you
just saw a deep health check
was being executed.
Now, let's install some add-ons starting
with HyperPod observability add-on.
It's just literally one click.
But although I'm enabling
some additional say,
advanced metrics, so it's not one click,
but I am literally, well, say,
one click in case of basic installation.
And then enabling
HyperPod task governance.
This is for, I say, task prioritization,
and a dynamic computer quota allocation
between multiple teams.
This is useful in case of, how to say,
sharing across between multiple
teams and multiple purposes.
So I'm configuring the, I say, priorities,
job priorities depending on the task types
like influencing,
training, or experiments.
And I'm also configuring two
teams, team A and team B,
and defining eight instances
as a default quota,
but allowing landing and
borrowing compute resource
between teams.
And then I'm configuring
training job, right?
So as you can see in the second
line, HyperPod training job,
it's custom resource definition installed
by a HyperPod training operator
and I'm using it for advanced training.
Installing additional software
and modifying checkpointing code in order
to enable manage the
(indistinct) checkpointing.
I will explain more later.
Yeah, so using some SageMaker
specific Python classes
for checkpointing code.
Now, on time now, I'm
monitoring three information,
top left, I'm monitoring the node status,
top right, portal status,
and center is log out to
put from training job,
I executed training job
using (indistinct) control.
There is standard CRI interface, alright?
Yeah, training is progressing.
Next, I'm going to, let's say,
inject artificial GPU failure
in order to simulate the,
and to verify the resiliency capability.
So a good feature of HyperPod
is you have direct access
to the infrastructure.
So not at the container-level,
not only just monitoring logs,
but you can log into computer
nodes like this by SSM session
and in this case, I
injected some error message
to the counter log to simulate hardware.
And you can see, yeah, so one
node became not ready status,
and one pod, I think it
became pending status.
So it means your job got suspended
because of the injected
artificially injected error.
And yeah, so new node came in,
thanks to that instance replacement,
and a new container is, let's say,
creating status now and soon
it should start executing.
Yeah, so container, say,
newly created container started
and job resumed like this.
And then yeah, job resumed.
The next step I'd like to show you
how the observability
dashboard looks like.
This is based on (indistinct)
and Amazon managed the (indistinct)
and Amazon managed the Grafana,
so I'm using task, say,
cluster dashboard first.
And the cluster dashboard
shows you hardware resource
related to information
at the cluster-level
or instance-level like this.
And next dashboard I'm
showing is task dashboard.
It's pretty powerful.
You can see key metrics like a CPU, GPU,
oh say, memory utilization
at a task level,
not instance level.
So because HyperPod is for distributed,
so useful for distributed training, right?
So I think you are
interested in which team
is using GPU efficiently,
which teams need improvement,
and which job is, let's
say, not performing well,
because of what, bottleneck, right?
So those informations are really important
to use cluster.
So this observability dashboard
is very useful for you.
Okay, so in the demo,
I included some newly
introduced features this year.
So let me highlight some new features.
The first feature I'd like to highlight
is enhanced HyperPod, say,
cluster creation experience
on management console.
And you can easily set
up cluster by, let's say,
entering some parameters.
And configuring cluster
can be very complex
because say, you need
to not only configure
the cluster itself, but
also prerequisite resources.
But you can use this
browser based experience
to easily configure a cluster.
Next feature is one click observability.
And so observability is
important for you as I said,
but setting up is complex,
because it requires
metric emitting component
on the cluster itself
and time series database
and visualization layer.
But yeah, you can literally
install this by one click.
And the HyperPod training operator,
this is for efficient
distributed training,
and it has capability to
recover intelligently.
It has a job hanging detection.
Managed tiered checkpointing.
This is to reduce the
overhead of checkpointing.
And this is a feature I
didn't include in my demo,
but AWS, sorry, training
job has a new feature,
AWS Batch support,
and training job itself doesn't
have a batch scheduling,
sorry, job scheduling capability,
it just runs training.
But by combining a SageMaker training job
and AWS batch, you can include
training job in the queue
and intelligently schedule by priority.
And this is also a new feature
I didn't include in the demo,
but say, now, you can
run IDEs and notebook
on a HyperPod cluster.
So you can use notebook, sorry,
HyperPod cluster not only
for learning training jobs,
but also for interactive
development and experiment.
And lastly, we released MCP Server.
So for SageMaker AI, so you
can use this MCP Server to,
I say, create and
maintain HyperPod cluster
by natural language.
For example, you can say,
create a cluster with a four
RG five (indistinct) instances
or you can also say, scale up
my cluster from four instances
to 80 instances by natural language.
Okay, so yeah.
So now, we covered fundamental concept
of SageMaker training capability.
And let's say, I provided
some demonstration.
Now, I think you are
interested in what HyperPod
or SageMaker AI capability
can do in real world, right?
So I'm interested, say, introduce
Denis Goupil from Roblox.
His team is using SageMaker HyperPod
for one of core components
of their AI platform.
- Thank you. Hello, can you hear me?
Cool. Yes.
So, I'm Denis.
I work at Roblox
where I lead the AI infrastructure
and AI platform team.
And so today I'm gonna
talk about AI at Roblox
to give you some context.
And then we dig into our
training infrastructure,
especially how it has been impacted
by training for 4D Foundation model,
finish by what we want to build next.
So if you are not familiar with Roblox,
Roblox is a platform where
million of people come together
to create, play, and
interact with each other
with one of the million of
experience that we have.
And those experiences have
been created by our community
of (indistinct).
And so as of last quarter,
we have 150 million daily active users,
and we eat 45 million peak concurrency.
That means that 45 million
people come together
to play at the same time in Roblox.
That's pretty huge.
And in terms of AI, our
AI infrastructure supports
about 1 million plus query per second
across our 350 plus,
50 model that we have
running in production.
So as you can see,
AI is pretty much everywhere
on what we do at Roblox.
And especially when it comes to safety,
which is core to our principle.
We train and we serve a model
for real time moderation,
for voice and for text just to make sure
that there is no bad content
that is happening within the platform.
And actually those models are open source
so you can use it for your own use cases.
For safety, we also do
bad avatar moderation
as well as bot detection, abuse report,
and clickbait detection.
So a lot of use cases of AI use
cases being used for safety.
For our players, AI
drives our recommendation
and search system just to make sure
and help our users to
get the right content.
So that means we have game recommendation
as you can see on the screen as well
as friend recommendation
for social interaction.
And for assets that you
can use for your game
or for your avatar,
we also have the marketplace
search driven by AI.
Finally for our creators we
introduced a set of gen AI tools
to help them improve
their creative processes.
And so in that example,
you have a creator
assistant built into Roblox
that helps you create a
three by three or upgrade
that's like one set of the assistance.
The other set is a script
that actually helps you turn
this blue (indistinct) into red
and disappear when a player touches it.
So similar that what you can
do as a developer using cursor,
we have the same set of
tools for our creators.
And more recently, we
introduced our cube model.
So it's a 4D object generation, and by 4D,
I mean it's a 3D object
that you can interact
and it's functional.
So for example, as you get a car,
you can actually open the
door and get into the car
and drive it and the wheel will turn.
And so there's two examples on the screen.
On the left side you have a gun,
a watermelon gun in the shape of a banana
that actually shoots watermelon.
And on the right side, you
have a magic carpet built
by our 4D model that you can fly.
That's pretty cool.
So you can see that in the future,
our players and creators will
be pretty much being able
to create anything that they can imagine.
Alright, so now let's
see how we actually train
this foundation model and how
our training infrastructure
has been impacted by that.
But first, let's step back
and look at the AI platform
as a whole to give you some context.
So on the left side in purple,
you have all our data components.
So starting with our data lake
with structure and unstructured data,
our feature store and embedding
where you can with online
and offline retrieval.
In the middle top, you
have the blue component
which is used for training,
so that's data processing.
So you go from raw data to
features for your training,
and actually the training
component itself.
So when you go for features
to like, build those model.
And then the yellow one is
what we use for serving.
So when you get your training
and you have your model,
you can push it to a model registry
and then you have our serving component
that reads the model from the registry
and serve it for real time
use cases as use case in green
and that's already described before.
And finally on the right side,
you have the rest of what
we use for observability,
cost tracking, and our
experimentation platform.
So that's pretty much
AI platform as a whole.
And so today we are going
to focus on this red box,
which is our distributed
training components.
So how we do multi GPU multi-node
in a distributed training fashion.
And spoiler alert,
is gonna use a HyperPod cluster obviously.
So let's go back to the 4D model
and to the scaling factor that
Michael was talking about.
And so how it's gonna be
applied to our use case.
So first was the data site.
In our case, we have about
100 million 3D assets
that are available that's like
roughly 6.5 petabyte of data.
We don't necessarily use
everything for training,
but that gives you an idea of the scale.
Then the model size, the
requirement was between 1 billion
and 70 billion parameters.
So it's a very large requirement.
We don't know exactly
what's gonna be built.
In terms of available hardware,
all we know is we will
need a lot of GPU memory
to train those models.
And so the New Year's better
and H200 is what we went for.
In terms of training technique,
the research team doesn't
have any specific requirement,
except that it starts to
be performant, stable,
and easy to use.
And finally, probably
the most important point
for them is the number of
jobs that they can run.
And why it's more important
is as we never train a foundation model,
and especially a 4D foundation model,
being able to run as many
jobs as possible in parallel,
makes them more efficient and actually
like refine the hypotheses that they need
to create that model and
especially the model size.
Alright, so how does that
affect our AI platform?
Well, first of all, you go
talk to your finance team
and making sure that you
have enough budget for it,
that's one.
But once you get the budget,
we actually sit down and look
at what is going to break
or what is missing from
our current solution.
And so we came up with three challenges.
The first one was how we
actually get capacity.
We already have thousand
of GPU across training
and inference, but those
are usually like tiny GPU
for inference or they're
used by other team.
And so in that case, we just
needed like more capacity
and more high performance GPU.
And so how we get that was one challenge.
The second challenge is, was
how do we ensure resiliency?
As Michael was describing,
as you get more data,
as the model size go
up, you are most likely
to fail at some point
during your training.
And so we have to make sure
that whatever this new project
is coming to the platform,
we have hundred of,
many engineers are
working on other project
that should not be stopped
because of a new project.
And the last one is, okay,
you get GPU, get capacity,
you get resiliency.
The first one is how we
make it like cost efficient
and making sure that we
utilize GPU resources
in the best way possible.
And that's where HyperPod
come into the picture
and helps us get there.
So the first point, was it
actually fairly easy to set up?
It's not, don't get me wrong,
not as easy as setting
up an easy two instances
or not good for your case
cluster, but it's reasonable.
It took us one month from
prototyping into production.
And so that includes
making sure that everything
that we do on the platform
works the same way
in a HyperPod cluster with InfoSec review
and actually setting up the network.
So our EKS control plan
can talk to HyperPod node.
And we recently created a
new EKS HyperPod cluster
and it took us less
than one hour to do it.
So I would say it's reasonable.
The next point was GPU
capacity, as I was saying,
we need this high-performance GPU,
and so HyperPod was one way to get there.
And especially that with HyperPod,
you have like multiple option
to get more capacity either
with reserved capacity,
spot instances or flexible training plan.
We don't choose flexible
training plan today,
but as we get more timely
or ephemeral project,
I do see that happening in the future.
Continuing on our HyperPod
helps us with those changes.
The next one was stability.
Again, as we scale up, a failure
is most likely to happen.
And so building those features
ourself will take a lot
of time and most likely
being delayed that project.
And so HyperPod helps us get there faster.
And actually as I was
preparing the slide for today,
I couldn't find a single node failure
in the last three months,
even so I can tell you
that there were a lot
of GPU utilization during that time.
So kudos to the team.
But as I mentioned that something
that is actually missing
though is some visibility
into the recurring node detection,
and like what failure (indistinct),
I would've loved to show you
actually a thousand of tests
that AWS is running behind the scene
where everything is green
and everything is fine.
I couldn't find this information,
so we should probably take that.
The last one is flexibility.
And honestly to us, that was
the most important point,
where you have an AI platform,
we already invest a lot of time with that,
where you have like tooling
that we want to reuse as much as possible.
And the fact that HyperPod
is able to integrate
with EKS is phenomenal to us.
And what I mean by that,
is when you create a HyperPod cluster,
your HyperPod node is going
to join your EKS cluster,
and at that point,
it looks like just any
other node in your cluster.
That means that you can turn those nodes,
you cannot do selection, you
can run any demand set on it,
and any tooling that you
have, can work the same way.
And so that means that
HyperPod is actually
like framework agnostics for
both scheduling and training.
And so in our case, that means
we were able to use unicorn
just like any user AI workload
that we have on the platform
and we are able to use Ray for
distributed training, again,
just like any other workload.
So that was definitely a
good selling point for us.
I'll finish with what
we want to build next,
and that's what we call
a decentralized compute.
The problem still remains the same.
Having access to GPU
is always a bottleneck.
And so HyperPod was able to
solve that in a single region,
single cluster environment.
But as we want to get
access to more capacity,
we need to extend that.
And so the solution that
we come up with is again,
what we call a decentralized compute.
And so we need a way to
schedule workloads dynamically
across all resources
that are available to us.
And it doesn't matter which
region, which cluster,
where the capacity is,
is all that matters.
And we need to make that in a
transparent way for our user.
And so how we are going to
abstract the scheduling process
so the user gets a unified experience,
and just schedule a job and submit it
and it doesn't actually care
of where it's actually running.
That's where we want to be.
And so finally that means that we want
to extend the HyperPod support
to get like multi-region
and multi cluster for that.
And so we hope to work
with the SageMaker team
to make that happen,
and hopefully, you can
benefit from it as well.
And that's all for me. I'll
let Michael do the recap.
- Thank you. Thank you very
much, Denis and Tomonori.
And thank you so much for sticking around.
We have just three more slides
to close out this session.
And as a quick recap, we talked
about the various dimensions
of the critical things that
are important to customers,
compute availability,
performance, resiliency,
observability, and ease of use,
and how those all apply to cost.
I recall Denis talked about
flexibility of choice,
and on this slide, we're
just gonna summarize that.
Right from the bottom of the stack,
for hardware we have multiple options,
different compute options,
storage, and networking.
On the software and driver layer,
we have multiple pre-built images,
different device drivers and toolkits.
Moving further up for
multiple training libraries
to ensure highly performant
distributed training
with PyTorch, TensorFlow,
multiple capabilities for
distributed training strategies
and even various MLOps
third party solutions,
we integrate with MLflow
or weights and biases.
For tools, you can submit
jobs with Ray or kubectl.
For observability like Tomonori showed,
we have support for Prometheus,
Grafana, or CloudWatch.
You can even use SageMaker
Studio or notebooks
or even use it directly from your machine
to actually submit jobs.
And at the top layer,
whether you're using HyperPod
to orchestrate your jobs with
Kubernetes and EKS or Slurm,
those options are available to you.
Or if you just want to
use a fully managed API,
you can actually use the
SageMaker training jobs
managed API.
So what this shows is we
understand that for you,
your use cases might be different,
your technology team might
have different interest
in using various frameworks.
We offer that capability for you to pick
and choose what works
best for your use case.
So we are sharing this link,
it's the link to a blog
where we discuss both the capabilities
for training jobs and HyperPod.
It's a good resource
that I usually recommend.
It also has example notebooks on GitHub
where you can literally
just copy the code and run.
So these examples are set up for you.
We have hundreds of them
available for you to get started.
So thank you so much for
joining this session,
and please leave feedback on
the app at the end of the day
or later on what we've really
enjoyed talking to you today.
We're gonna also be outside
if you have more questions
or things you want us to talk about.
But thank you very much and
enjoy the rest of re:Invent.